so now you see my title tape we're going
to talk about deep learning and machine
learning in our so by now we all have
seen this Venn diagram right you have to
have this by our very own drew Conway
the original progenitor of the arc meet
up and it's like a rule you need to show
this at a data science Meetup all right
there's even data science bingo and this
is one of the slots that you need to
fill but there's rumblings of a new Venn
diagram this comes from the deep
learning book and what it says is that
AI is this encompassing field and that
machine learning is a subset of that and
within machine learning you have deep
learning now some people say that deep
learning is its own thing not comparable
to the rest of the machine learning
other people will just say it's one
technique of machine learning so we're
gonna dive into both of those for a
little bit but first when you're getting
into them you need to learn about them
so we need some good books and there's
plenty of good books in both fields on a
theoretical side you have the elements
of statistical learning by hasty tip
Johnny and Friedman then you have deep
learning right to the point
by good fellow Ben geo and kohrville now
these are both math books they're heavy
a math heavy on theory if you want to
learn how to do the code we have applied
predictive modeling by Max where are you
max right there and deep learning with
our by JJ lair where's JJ JJ somewhere
there is now these books are just code
so if you wanted to learn the theory
first read the other two books you want
to learn code read these two books
highly recommend all four of them
they're really really good reads take it
with you when you go to the beach
excellent for that now the two
disciplines have the same things but
different words some reason there's been
a massive split and the terminology used
between machine learning and deep
learning and it could be infuriating
all right let's see some examples of
that
first up we have linear regression
because that is solves a majority of
your problems
so first up and it looks like we do not
have internet for my slide so my latex
math is gone
oh no Playtex map is there I just live
in my screen wonderful y equals a plus
BX simple linear regression we've all
seen this I hope we've all seen this if
you haven't seen it in terms of
statistics this is slope intercept form
from middle school all right we've had
it a and B but those terms have very
different words depending what field
you're in machine learning calls it an
intercept deep learning calls it a bias
then the B term what comes after that
machine learning calls the coefficients
whereas deep learning calls them wait
well that's a problem because in
statistics a bias is something
completely different in the
bias-variance tradeoff huge important
concept and weights in statistics are
how much you value each row so it's
they're completely reusing terms not
just a new term they're reusing a term
and that could be very difficult to get
your head around then we have this curve
it is generically a binary scaling curve
right we all know the math behind this
it's 1 over 1 plus e to the negative x
all right well depending on your field
it's either either an inverse logit or a
sigmoid we needed a new word for cos
inverse logit just didn't sound cool
then we have l2 penalization incredibly
important shows up in a lot of
algorithms and beyond machine learning
of statistics it shows up everywhere
this is essentially the sum of the
squares of the terms very important
penalty
it's the l2 norm the squared l 2-norm
actually and a machine learning that's a
ridge and in deep learning it's weight
decay
and then when it comes time when you
have new data and you're trying to score
your new data well that is in
mathematical terms y hat equals F hat of
X tilde in machine learning that's
prediction and in deep learning that's
inference but that word is really
problematic so you're using it for
prediction here but in statistics
inference means explanation you're
actually explaining things and the first
time I heard people talking about using
inference for prediction I'm like that's
just wrong but throughout history
there's been lots of terms for the same
thing you just got to learn when to use
which one depending on your crowd so
let's get into some R code that's we're
all here for today the examples are
going to be looking at our supervised
learning y is a function of X that's
majority what people do in particular
particularly we are going to look at
binary classification because let's be
honest 90% of the time when someone has
AI they're doing a logistic regression
so let's take a look at this let's first
look at machine learning traditional ml
and we're going to focus on today just
two algorithms glim net and X G boost
probably two of the most important
powerful algorithms in machine learning
for either one the first thing we have
to do is set up our matrices so in when
you're using LM or g LM you could just
put in your formula and the data frame
it all works nicely you can't do that
with these algorithms you need to
provide the matrices in numeric format
ahead of time fortunately the useful
package there's a function called build
X that will build a for you and build y
you give it the formula like you would
have for a regular model give your data
frame and in this case I'm saying
contrast equals false this way we don't
drop the baseline of categorical
variables and sparse equals true to have
a sparse matrix because sparse matrices
take up less space and they compute
faster I'm using the credit data so it's
a nice small data set tiny data that
everyone's familiar with now while I use
build X for this it is theoretically
possible to use the recipes package but
the functionality I wanted wasn't ready
yet by time I wrote this but mat
just promise me it's on github already
thank you max just a little too late for
me so let's talk about the elastic net
which is a combination of l1 and l2
penalization and that's implemented in
glim net by hasty tips Ronny Friedman
and the really cool thing about that
package is it's actually written in 73
lines of Fortran that's it and everyone
your molecular know that fortran's of
verbose language and they somehow did
that it's amazing what they did
so let's fit our first model with one
line of code we not only fit a penalized
regression we did cross-validation over
the lambda we fed it the X we fed it the
Y told it's a binomial regression and do
ten folds and one line of code we got
all of that done nice simple easy and
when we're done of that we can visualize
the coefficient path using coop F if
you're used to using the gloom net
package you could plot the model but
it's static it's hard to see so I used I
graphs to build coop ass which now has
it interactively you can zoom in you can
hover and see what's happening and as
you read this you can see that as your
lambda your penalty increases the
coefficients shrink towards zero and
eventually they get to zero and that's
your minimization nice quick easy
visualization let's say you have one
value of lambda and you want to see the
point estimates for your coefficients
you can use cough plot tell it you want
to use lambda dot min and it very
quickly shows you the point estimates
for each of your coefficients much
better than a table of numbers out to
like five decimal places you can very
quickly and easily see the impact of
each individual coefficient now of
course if you're using a regular linear
model you would have confidence
intervals but penalize regression
doesn't give you confidence intervals
but who cares about that anyway these
days no one seems to care about
confidence intervals all right is
machine learning and making a prediction
that's going to last five seconds so you
don't care anymore but maybe you should
that is penalized regression the next
algorithm I want to talk about our
decision trees and despite their name of
decision tree they actually do both
regression and classification
they're called decision trees not
because of the outcome variable was
because of a series of decisions as you
split up the input variables and well
there's lots of ways you can do this
we're going to skip straight to X G
boost because it's just like the most
awesome thing put out there machine
learning recently before we actually fit
the model we're going to take one more
data step we're going to create a
special object an x gb d matrix which
stores the x and y variables in one
object for you to keep them together
we're doing that before our training
data and our validation data but notice
this they call the X the X matrix data
and the Y matrix label regression was
clearly an afterthought when they were
building this right otherwise they would
have called it X and Y or predictor and
response or input and output they were
clearly thinking about classification
but now that we have our data ready
let's fit the model with one line of
code sure I broke it up on multiple
lines so it would fit on the screen but
it's just one line of code you give it
that special data set you tell it you
want to use GB tree and that's cool
because you switch it to GB linear it's
gonna fit an elastic net XG boost can
fit penalized regression models we're
gonna stick to the tree you tell it's a
logistic model I do 500 rounds I said
early stopping I give it validation data
and I get a nice model and what's really
cool is this works on a GPU now boosted
trees are sequential but when you're
searching for the split in each of the
trees that could be in parallel and you
could do it on a GPU and it could be
incredibly fast even faster the next
reboost already is and you can even have
an experimental concept here where you
could do a boosted random forest that's
really awesome you can fit multiple
trees in parallel and then boost those
groups of parallel trees when you've
done of this you get a variable
importance plot and you can very quickly
see which variables were important in
the fitting
not the impact of the variables but the
importance of them and if you want to
try to visualize all 500 trees in one
you can it does its best to compress 500
trees into one tree and show you
representative splits is this
understandable in the slightest no but
it's a good first effort and we will
applaud them for that but in case you
want it to be even simpler we can use
the carrot package this provides a
uniform interface in our for all the
machine learning needs it's incredibly
simple and it's been around for over a
decade this is the original Auto ml they
couldn't ask for anything better than
this so there's two models I just fit
each one can be done in a single line of
code if you have a formula a data frame
and the only difference between these
two snippets of code are the method one
is glim net one is xgb tree so thank you
max for making it so easy so that's
machine learning very quickly next we
have deep learning and everyone's
excited about deep learning now right
it's all the rage but I think a better
name for it is extreme nonlinear
modeling because that's where you're
getting the power from it's the
nonlinearities
it's the activation functions that give
you the nonlinearities and that's where
the real strength is that's yxg boost
works so well it's capturing nonlinear
relationships the two primary ways of
doing this in our rmx net and Karis MMX
net is championed by Amazon and Karis
and tensorflow by Google there's a
slight issue you can't have both of them
loaded in the same our session but JJ
lares promised to fix for me he I'm
taking that as a promise now we can do
other neural networks in our end net by
Brian Ripley has been around for decades
but could only do single layer you can
also do CMT K deep net RNN dark RCP PDL
there's no shortage of deep learning in
our despite what people say there's many
packages to do it in our
so first let's rebuild our matrices same
as before but we can't use sparse
matrices because neither MX net nor
Karis slash tensorflow
can handle sparse matrices that's ok
though because we're going to have large
data we can use iterators and generators
to load them into memory a little bit at
a time because they use stochastic
gradient descent they don't need all the
data so first let's look at MX net this
was for a while the primary way to do it
in our it's portable to Windows Linux
Android raspberry Pi and a CPU or GPU
this is an MX net model a simple MX net
model we first do a layer dropout to
prevent overfitting we have a fully
connected layer which is a dense layer
all the inputs are connected to all of
the temporary in-between nodes we use a
rel u activation function we do dropout
then we do another fully connected layer
of another round at dropout and another
value until we get to our last layer
which is just one because it's binary
and it's 1 or 0 and we have an output a
logistic regression output and that's
the sigmoid output or the inverse load
yet we're not ready yet we need helper
functions we first need to write our own
custom log loss function because it's
not one built-in so we use log loss
because that's better than binary loss
and if you want to keep track of your
results you need to create a logger to
keep track of your metrics as you go so
now that we build that we can go fit the
model so first you need to feed it your
x and y matrices you tell you the
optimizer you want I chose Adam for
adaptive momentum you give it your
valuation data to see how you're going
I'm doing this on a CPU I'm choosing to
use log loss as my metric I'm doing 50
passes through the data I set my
learning rate I set my batch size I tell
it how the data set up I have a callback
to check my metrics and then I'd say
verbose and I could run this a lot of
options you need to set just right so
then we get the outcome of this and we
can plot it using digraphs and we can
see how we're doing over time clearly
this data sets not appropriate for deep
learning it's a very messy thing our
loss functions all over the place but
you get
you can see how you're doing and our
dataset definitely needs to train for
much longer if we want to keep doing
this well let's see the new kid in town
let's check out Karis this is a port of
Karis thanks to JJ lair and Francois
Chalet and you by default it uses
tensorflow as a back-end it's primarily
meant for Linux but it does work on Mac
and on Windows and you can use a GPU
mostly on Linux I tried a few ways to
hack it into Windows but it's mostly on
Linux let's design our network this is a
similar network to before but using
Kerris notation and our first layer
which is a lake called a layer dense now
we tell it we want 512 nodes and instead
of specifying the activation layer
separately we specify it right in the
layer dense function and for your first
layer you need to tell at the input
shape which if you take your dimensions
you forget the one that's about the
number of samples is the number of
features and if you have
multi-dimensional tensors you have to
give a few of these but for our data set
we just tell the number of columns we
then do batch normalization to help with
the fit we do drop out then we do
another dense layer another passional
ization another drop out and we do a
sigmoid output but after we set up the
network we then have to compile it we
set the optimizer to be Adam again and
this time our loss function is binary
cross-entropy
which is the same thing as log loss but
we needed a new word we use accuracy as
our metric and notice here you're not
saving this back to an object it's not
like traditional are you're modifying
the variable in place so net Kerris has
now been modified by calling compile on
it and is a different object now it's
been changed it's been mutated so it's
very important to note it's a little
different than standard R so now that
we've compiled it we can go ahead and
train our model we tell it the number of
epochs the batch size you want our
validation data again and then we say
callbacks because you can't just say
early stopping you need to call back
that at the end of each epoch it says
hey should I stop you need a callback
for showing us your
Metrix you need to call back for
changing your learning rate you need to
call back for tensor board so after
you've gone and trained the model this
time only on ten epochs you can once
again see how you're doing over time and
compare your training and validation set
clearly our model needs a lot of work we
need to train it more and maybe use
different data set but that's the goal
behind this not every data set is from
suited for deep learning so wrapping up
let's what's the big picture of this
well you could use centuries old terms
or you could use brand new terms for
machine learning there are many many
many packages carrot has 238 algorithms
you could choose from deep learning
there's about seven but deep learn has
only been around for a few years so it
is a very very good start machine
learning for the most part you could do
in a one line of code but in deep
learning it takes many many lines of
code so you have to know what you're
doing it's more verbose machine learning
we have carrot thank goodness and deep
learning there is carrot but could only
do simple networks it can't really do
extreme deep networks you can do simple
networks machine learning you might get
some explanation out of your models if
you're doing a linear model and maybe a
single tree decision tree deep learning
it's just for predictions and machine
learning we're already give you strong
predictions and deep learning might give
you better predictions when it does
better it does really better
it really does better now we're they're
both the same they both have some really
really great books out there like I
showed earlier I highly recommend all of
those and both fields still have a ton
of excitement about it and that everyone
is very deeply excited about all of
these so thank you very much
you
you